it's craving time reject Nation we are
joined by John John how are you I am
craving this trailer Coy you are sweaty
because I called you when you're at the
gym getting a pump on time to get a pump
and some Sony on it's commitment right
there ladies and Gentlemen please go
ahead leave a like on this video that
would mean a lot there's a couple things
I want to mention if you miss our flash
spoiler talk on Saturday we announced
that we are going to be having a
Comic-Con panel a real rejects Comic-Con
panel Saturday July 22nd just a few
hours before Marvel more details to come
sooner rather than later secondly this
video is sponsored by a drink that I'm
drinking right now G fuel if you look at
my fridge you'll see that I've got so
much G fuel in there look at that the
reason I want to shout them out in this
video is because everyone grab a tub
they have these spider-verse exclusive
flavors right now and if you use code
reject Nation get 20 off select tubs
right now I'm drinking the one in John's
hand and it is delicious you guys know
I'm obsessed with G fuel these two love
G fuel they're constantly stealing it
from me and I say fine whatever I guess
I'll be a nice employer today but
seriously G Phil you know how much I
love you you guys got to know by this
point I'm always drinking it even when
they're not in a sponsored post
s
[Music]
oh it's a Sony movie
spider verse
my son never show Mercy
plus a pro they are playing
the Predators
I love that Russell Crowe agreed to do
this your mother is dead
she died because you sent her away she
was weak sick in her mind a chameleon
business oh is it on the left yeah
Power is about strength
if you show weakness
give our enemies an opening
befriend it shot lioness are in it that
becomes his vest
or does it
fake like his mother leave him
what happened that day what
what it's Chris he's like Charlie Sheen
he's got Tiger Blood The Lion for the
first time I saw my true self and he
doesn't have an accent tell me about
this Hunter
uses a connection with animals to track
his prey
once you're on his list
there's only one way off here's a
radioactive line there's six of you now
[Music]
okay okay
you are you're saving this hunting for a
trophy
murderers
is not what he taught
Callisto you don't get to do that to me
anymore
[Music]
all the jacket
Mr tackling
where's Mr tagline oh you're standing in
him
you're a goddamn lunatic oh you just
figured that out now
yeah
let's go
interesting last time
there is an animal in each one of us
don't you want to know why they call me
the Rhino whoa what damn
we're getting like an actual Rhino it's
gonna turn into a rhino yeah I mean
so this is not in The Amazing Spider-Man
universe
ah spider versus okay that felt like
typical Sony Marvel trailer I was like
oh God we're going down this path again
the second blood and gore and violence
started happening I forgot we were
watching a red band trailer for a second
and then I was like this this is all you
needed to do this whole time yeah
prevent him and morbius if you're gonna
go like Sony Marvel schlock at least
just make it violent
and they listen they listen Dave the
trailer entirely for me and suddenly
went from oh God it's radioactive lion
it is he doesn't have an accent too yes
yes yes yes yes yes and there and Taylor
Johnson's looking badass this is great
yeah that trailer uh had a full 360 spin
that was that was a journey for me that
was an emotional journey and he like he
looks great in like the full lion
um what the hell is that called
Sylvester just a vest it's the lion fur
right yeah it's got the main on it yeah
uh yeah I I like the trailer
I did not expect to have that experience
of
too hell yeah
all right Johnny please take it away
yeah I absolutely agree I think it's
smart of them to build on their like you
know kind of goofy-ish but fun sort of
90s quality by making it that much more
of an exploitation movie I love the all
all the different animals and stuff and
watching as he takes on different
properties of the animal kingdom to hunt
down human beings and for animal lovers
out there I have to imagine this will be
a very cathartic movie because you're
just gonna watch a Murk a ton of
terrible people and I know they changed
bits of his character and what not being
the hunter now to being sort of a
protector a commuter with animals yeah I
want to call bits of changes
changes
the origin but at the same time I'm kind
of here for that and I think you know
somebody who represents and fights for
and with the animal kingdom is a badass
ideas yeah this looks awesome and there
are Taylor Jobs it looks great he does
look great I am liking the way it's shot
too it looks better than morbius like
the the cinematography I'm talking about
specifically the lighting looks sharper
cleaner and I like the variation between
the jungle and the different
environments and all that so yeah but
koi had to know that was chameleon okay
so his little brother Dimitri is who
chameleon is in the comic books it's a
half brother uh he's usually seen as
more small and slight and blonde so that
to the left is in the car uh later when
he's reintroduced he's going to be
someone I assume that is uh basically
siding with Craven but something puts
them at odds maybe like a trail from the
father at one point he says in the
trailer you look just like father so I
think there's going to be like that
undercurrent of family and Legacy and
maybe they're fighting over the Legacy
what I find most interesting is they not
only introduce Callisto in this which is
huge in the torment Saga which is Todd
McFarlane's first solo writing and
illustrating Ron on Spider-Man I was
introducing like 1990 Spider-Man number
one Callisto come on I'm getting there
but it's very iconic imagery used in the
torment uh Saga that they put in here
the spider's coming down is not only
introduced in the torment Saga but also
it is in Craven's last hunt now this is
obviously not going to touch on craving
the last hunt but allowing that industry
I don't want it to touch on Craven's
life we want it together no we hate the
best stories last time we hate that he's
a hunter if you introduce in the
beginning those those images and those
uh hallucinations I think will be a
really good way to have the potion come
into play to have him start to lose his
mind and I'm thinking that's going to
tie into how we fight Spider-Man so what
I think this is going to be is they've
got Rhino who is in this case
transforming I think instead of having
him put in a suit that he's stuck in
he's going to transform too many times
he gets stuck as the Rhino which would
be an interesting conversation about
like him poaching poachers and him
hunting animals and this man who's using
an animal power to take out humans
interesting commentary there but also it
might be something with the chameleon
where chameleon can transform his skin
so I'm wondering if something happens
that is the Rhino's powers that allows
chameleon to use his powers or if he
influences the Rhino but I think all of
that ties in with Callisto who has the
ability to cause these potions and to
have all these African herbs that give
Craven bigger Powers but it that's his
mind so I think Callisto is going to be
either the big bad or cause the big bad
in the film so showing her in the
trailers are interesting and allowing
that to lead to the greater spider-verse
and using the sound design from across
the spider-verse a lot of those sounds
and horns and things I think are all
going to make a bigger web I agree with
50 of what you're saying that's fair I
think you are you have some great
theories there of where this will
ultimately lead to
and I feel like a lot of times you pitch
these ideas that are often way better
than what we get I should be higher
have said that you ought to have been
you ought to be hired many people have
expressed that sentiment because I would
use it as chameleon being Rhino as a
commentary on this brotherly rivalry and
that's why his power set is different
and then that it's a big reveal in
betrayal so the expectation the audience
is as Rhino but that would actually tie
to his power set but I think they'll
just actually be involved so they have
more toys
that's what I mean
but uh thank you for all the information
there
um that was great that was excellent
It's Gonna be great this year but the
fact that he's going to be also in
Marvel Spider-Man 2. where we're going
to get a more accurate version of
craving over but at least we got this we
got two versions of crib we got this
version of Craven and then we're gonna
have the accurate version represented in
Marvel Spider-Man 2. uh so yeah I mean I
was really surprised by this I really
liked it a lot I liked it a lot more
than I expected he looks great man it's
JC shondor tooted through uh triple
Frontier as well I really like this
director I think it is going to tie into
the legacy of family and all those
things and I think uh casting Russell
Crowe is going to be a really Powerhouse
moving parts of the transformation with
Rhino that look that'll remind me of
like Amazing Spider-Man one specifically
yeah yeah absolutely
um but hey guys uh I love and look at
this I'm loving the violence loving the
gore I'm a simple man to please when it
comes to this lower expectations that
I'm more than satisfied that's how we do
this what did you guys think about the
trailer were you surprised by it leave
your thoughts down below thank you koi
for rushing on over here from the gym he
sprinted from Hollywood to the area I
live in uh subscribe leave a like click
that Bell last one Lisa Simpsons
I want to shout out Omni media Michael B
today because I'm sure right now he is
doing exactly what we're doing hustling
to get his trailer reaction up here on
the YouTubes and he is one of the best
reactors and my personal opinion who's
out there I feel like he should be way
more popular than all of us especially
koi I think he should be exceptionally
more popular and one of these days do
when you move out to California I
promise you I'm hiring your ass and
you're just going to join here and
replace someone one of the people in
this video
Roxy strong
see you guys
[Music]